that's where we begin with coronavirus
the scale of the coronavirus crisis is
growing dramatically all over the world
there are now more than 1 million
reported cases of illnesses Anthony and
nearly 1/4 of those cases are right here
in the United States
yeah Gayle the numbers can the numbers
continue to surge in hotspots like
California Michigan Louisiana Florida
and especially of course New York
medical resources are stretched to
capacity and beyond in New York the navy
hospital ship comfort was supposed to
help relieve that pressure by handling
non coronavirus patients but as of now
just 20 of its 1,000 beds are being used
we start with our lead national
correspondent David Begg know who's at
New York's Javits Convention Center
which is now a military field hospital
David Anthony look it was never supposed
to be a hospital that accepted Kovac
patients the idea is this would accept
the overflow but yesterday the governor
of New York asked the president mr.
president will you accept coltd patients
here and let the military run it and the
president said yes about 25 blocks north
of where we are is where the u.s. naval
ship comfort is docked here in Manhattan
and Anthony what hospital executive told
the New York Times it is absurd that the
military would send a big ole ship like
that in parking here and not accept
Kovac patients the hospitals are
overloaded the ship's got a thousand
beds but it only has 20 patients the
question now is will the governor of New
York go back to the President and ask
him will you let that ship start
accepting Kovac patients the things that
I see in the ER are scary
this is a video diary from dr. Matthew
by in it he's describing what he says he
sees every day at Mount Sinai Hospital
in Queens you can see all the rooms are
filled these halls are very neat and
empty
and there you can see there's patients
everywhere because of this some nurses
in the Bronx took to the streets
Thursday to protest the lack of personal
protective equipment every day when I go
to work I feel like a sheep going to
slaughter New York is one of several
states where the governor continues to
say they are low on ventilators at the
current burn rate we have about six days
of ventilators in our stockpile take
Louisiana they've requested 14,000
ventilators but they've received fewer
than 500 from the federal government an
admiral who's leading FEMA supply chain
task force confirmed that federal
supplies are not going directly to the
states they are going to a middleman
distributor and governor's say that's
when they're forced to bid against each
other for the equipment we have not
gotten a line on any additional
ventilators meanwhile in Richmond
Virginia 16 people have died at a rehab
facility where more than 100 residents
they are tested positive despite the
best efforts of the medical staff were
still seeing really significant spread
in New Jersey nearly 1 and 3 of the
long-term care facilities have at least
one positive case this crisis has hit
very close to home for Daniel drum he's
a member of the New York City Council
five of his friends have died from the
virus so far the mayors of New York and
Los Angeles are now asking their
residents to wear masks scarves anything
they have to cover their faces and we're
waiting to see if the President and the
CDC may issue that same guidance today
Tony get this here in New York State the
need for personal protective equipment
is still so real that yesterday the
governor posted a tweet saying if you
can manufacture PPE I implore you to do
so we will pay you a premium and please
email us at this address that's the
state of where things are right now it
says a lot there David begged Oh for us
in New York David thank you